[Musik]
mittlerweile drei monate oder im dritten
monat tobt der krieg in der ukraine
putins blutiger krieg der dort
weitergeht und wir wollen uns heute
wieder einmal verschiedene fronten
ansehen finden an denen russland
versucht vorzurücken fronten an den ergo
keine versucht sich zu verteidigen und
wir schauen uns erst einmal kurz die die
gesamtlage im land an
nämlich nimmt hier im osten des landes
gibt es eben weiterhin diese groß auch
wenn sie wird diese ob wir sehen hier
oben in der region aktiv in den regionen
lugansk und nun netz überall versucht
russland vorzurücken aber wenn wir uns
genau das angucken dann sehen wir die
forscher sind sehr sehr langsam sind
sehr kleine vorstellte die dort gelungen
sind und den ukrainern klingt es auch
immer mehr diese riesige russische
offensive dort aufzuhalten teilweise
sogar zurückzuschlagen trotzdem die
realität ist russland rückt weiter vor
und russland hat gestern wir haben es
gehört eine großstadt eingenommen die
standpartner eine stadt in der region
lugansk und wir wollen ist das ein mal
angucken wie es dort aussieht und das
sind leider wenn man so möchte die
altbekannten bilder wir sehen hier
tschetschenische kämpfer der russischen
armee also kämpfer von von herrn ramzan
kadyrow auf diesen tschetschenen führer
der aber putin direkt unterstellt ist
und die gehen hier durch die trümmer von
pro partner eine stadt die ehemals
20.000 einwohner hat auch diese stadt
und deshalb ist es für mich persönlich
schlimm dass zu sehen habe ich selbst
besucht bin dadurch gefahren habe dann
menschen gesprochen 2009 10 das ist
alles so völlig in trümmern zu sehen und
alle menschen geflüchtet zu sehen ist
natürlich wirklich grausig wir sehen
also hier man feiert offenbar die
sogenannte befreiung und befreiung heißt
in dem fall nichts anderes als die
komplette zerstörung entvölkerung der
stadt und sämtliche menschen die da
einmal gelebt haben sind entweder tot
verletzt oder geflüchtet die ukraine hat
diese stadt sechs wochen lang verteidigt
wir sehen sie also wirklich eine
großstadt mit zehnstöckigen häusern
oder nicht die großstadt 20.000
einwohner aber ist ein relativ große
stadt für die region und da mittlerweile
nur noch tschetschenische einheiten
wagner söldner wissen wir haben
mitgeholfen diese stadt zu erobern und
eben reguläre russischer soldaten dass
also die russischen vor märsche die dort
die dort weiter vorangehen wir wollen es
aber auch mal ansehen was die ukraine
machen nämlich
noch mal ganz kurz
europa ist dieser vorsprung hier ist
dieser rote zipfel sozusagen unter gramm
atos der erobert wurde wir gucken uns
jetzt die region easy um hier oben auch
dort versuchen die russen weiter
vorzudringen doch dort gelingt es den
ukrainern immer besser die russische
offensive zurückzuschlagen und zwar nach
altbekanntem muster wenn man so will wir
haben also die organischen drohnen die
sich ganz genau die ziele ansehen die
sich angucken wo verstecken sich die
russen wo sind die schweren artillerie
geschütze der russin versteckt und
natürlich sind sie in diesen wäldern
zwischen den feldern das kennen wir auch
aus deutschland als also man hat ein
großes feld dann eine kleine weltreise
unternehmen ein zweites großes feld wir
haben eben kurzem foto gesehen acacia
heißen die zwei s3 artilleriegeschütze
und die ukraine machen dann das was sie
am besten können nicht mit ihrer
lasergestützten artillerie mit dieser
genauen artillerie die ganz genau
treffen kann diese ziele anzugreifen die
vorher von der drohne aufgeklärt wurde
wurden und wir geben einfach mal weiter
nach vorne und sehen dann wie
erfolgreich das ganze ist wir haben also
hier eine riesige explosion
wir sehen immer im detail dort werden
also die russischen geschützte die dort
stehen die russischen geschützte die
sich verstecken von dort aus auf
afghanische soldaten und städte schießen
werden dort angegriffen und werden dort
eben zur explosion gebracht wir sehen
hier ein artilleriegeschütz was brennt
und was jetzt gleich explodiert wenn
nämlich die gesamte munition die in und
um diesen geschützt gelagert ist dort
sozusagen sich sich in luft auflöst da
sehen wir es ein riesiges schockwelle
alle soldaten alle russischen soldaten
die dort stationiert waren sind tot und
wir können mit sicherheit sagen dass
jeden tag zwischen 100 und 200 russische
soldaten dort sterben während also putin
den sieg feiert sozusagen über
nazi-deutschland natürlich und das ganze
propagandistisch auch benutzt um in
diesen krieg zu verteidigen sterben
seine soldaten jeden tag zu mindestens
100 in der ukraine wir wollen uns doch
eine weitere schlacht ansehen und zwar
nicht im osten sondern wir gucken uns
jetzt mal den den süden des landes an
hier unten man sieht es kaum das ist die
schlangen insel diese kleine schlangen
insel die am anfang des krieges von
ukraine verteidigt wurde die haben sich
dann zurückgezogen weil ich einfach eine
riesige russische übermacht aus schiffen
vor ihnen waren
versuchen uns das auch noch mal noch mal
so an zu sehen also eine sehr kleine
insel wo man ein geschenk tja was soll
das warum ist sie dann so wichtig hier
sehen sie aber wir werden gleich sehen
diese insel ist extrem wichtig für die
russische armee wenn die russische armee
hat den willen besser was wir hier sehen
abzuschneiden von der westlichen
versorgung von jeder art von von blut
schafft und wir haben die besetzt krim
auf der einen seite aber auf der anderen
seite haben wir hier unten rumänien
haben wir moldawien das heißt wir haben
auch nato gebiet dort in der nähe und
wir haben dort die möglichkeit noch dass
dort nachschub lang kommt deshalb ist
diese kleine insel hier im schwarzen
fleck extremste wichtig für die russen
diese zu besetzen um eben hier könnte es
auch kurz mal ein zeichnen um eben hier
sozusagen einen einem jahr seinen
vorhang zu schaffen um im odessa
abzuschneiden vor der von der versorgung
und dass sie quasi alles auch unter ihre
kontrolle zu bringen ohne dort überall
präsent zu sein die ukraine wollen das
verhindern und wir sehen uns einfach mal
an wie das in den letzten tagen passiert
ist das ist die schlangen insel die
russland versucht hat anzugreifen und
russland hat dann seine landungsschiffe
geschickt das heißt russland ist mit
schiffen dort ran gefahren und hat
versucht diese insel die kurzzeitig leer
war nachdem der ukraine abgezogen sind
dort zu besetzen aber was russland nicht
weiß oder auch immer weiß aber nichts
dagegen machen kann ist dass hier immer
eine ukrainische drohne überfliegt und
zwar vom typ bayraktar eine eine
türkische drohne und diese drohne wir
sehen dass hier
schießt auf die landungsschiffe und
zerstört dann wie russischen schiffe die
dort ankommen und das ist ziemlich
dramatisch weil wir sehen dass hier
wirklich viele luftangriffe erfolgen
dass die russen auch immer keine
möglichkeit haben sich dagegen zu wehren
und
in den letzten tagen haben die russen
ihre strategie geändert das heißt sie
haben versucht zu sagen okay wenn wir da
nicht mehr mit schiffen hinkommen weil
unsere schiffe so sehr gefährdet sind
dann versuchen wir es mit hubschraubern
sie haben also gesagt okay wir setzen
unsere spezialtruppen dortmund
hubschrauber auf der insel ab und das
letzte was wir uns angucken wollen diese
hubschrauber
sind jetzt hier gleich zu sehen da sehen
wie ein hubschrauber hier oben hier
steht er und wir sehen wie die leute
munition ausladen das heißt wir sehen
russischer soldaten die sich darum
bewegen munition ausladen und versuchen
so zu sagen hier einen stützpunkt
aufzubauen also hier eine präsenz auf
der insel aufzubauen doch auch hier das
ganze gefilmt von einer ukrainischen
drohne sehen wir weder der hubschrauber
noch die soldaten außenrum überleben
dieses a abenteuer die ukrainische
drohne vom typ bayraktar zerstört den
hubschrauber zerstört die menschen dort
die soldaten dort mittlerweile ist es
auch bestätigt von russischen quellen
dass dort die sami acht hubschrauber
eben von der beirat ohne zerstört wurde
also der kampf um die schlangen insel
ist noch lange nicht zu ende ein kleines
stück land mitten im schwarzen meer
russland will es unbedingt haben die
ukraine hält weiter tapfer dagegen
[Musik]